bonjour et bien maïté aujourd'hui je
crois que c'est la fête
qu'est-ce qu'on a une reine un souverain
on ne sait pas enfin quelque chose d
isère rhône elle un roi qu'est ce que
c'est un veuf blanc d'aquitaine à c'est
un boeuf ou là dessus oui pendant ce que
vous êtes sur leurs gardes
il a tout ce qu'il faut faire un boeuf
dans celui de vache
j'étais sûr que vous vous trompiez bon
alors c'est qui les rênes
c'est une race et une oreille alors si
j'ai bien une véritable aubaine libérale
elle a gagné son concours 1,93 à paris
au concours en cliquant au concours
agricole est la terre plus belle de
toutes les îles a eu un label rouge
pareil et là tout ce qu'il faut pour
faire quelque chose d'extraordinaire
alors soyons ici parce que vous devez
vous demander un peu s'ils ne vont pas
des salades entre les mâles et les
femelles
c'est bien une blonde d'aquitaine oui
mais l'avion que vous pouvez trouver sur
le marché
débouché le label rouge boeuf blonds
d'aquitaine et bien il provient de la
londe
c'est ce mélange des mâles et des
femelles compliqué pour le savoir mais
n'hésitez pas c'est toujours la blonde
d'aquitaine armes a été cette merveille
prime et ce pour quoi la ses superbes
couleurs de la france parce que elle est
blonde
c'est à dire qu'elle est les rouages
voilà l epr et trapu plus encore que
rolala parce que moi je pèse mais elle
pèse quand même 1100 kg une tendance
éternité que vous et moi qui ne sommes
pas particulièrement fier que nous
allons sûrement assez mince un côté
quand même ça c'est agréable
la première fois grâce en mer ce alors
en plus câline scaling malades à la
lèpre et très câline toute façon c'est
vrai gentil très doux et alors elle a 5
ans et demi sur moulins et à leurs
critiques se trouve email mais le jour
du 14 juillet ici comme là-bas langue
serait ce qu'elle aime dans les limbes
rural et là alors on rana les comptes
dans tes lecteurs aux lignes d et
regardez moi ça c'est une beauté
c'est une beauté ces nouvelles puces
alors maïté cette grande beauté
qu'est-ce que vous avez l'intention n'en
a pas tout dit
il fallait dire quand même que c'est une
des races les plus exhaustives dans
notre pays puisque en âge pavia loin de
la ligne
j'espère que je me trompe pas qu'en plus
c'est un ça commence à être un produit
d'exportation et vous savez combien à
titre économique l'exportation c'est
important pour notre pays
on a déjà exporté près de 20000 sushis
crois pas que ce soit le mot exact soit
des techniciennes c'est sa voilure la
semence les paillettes j'ai pas quoi
enfin on a fait des petites blondes
d'aquitaine aux états unis environ 20000
pas mal c'est brillant dit mais en
attendant nous on va non et bien voilà
face à la mais de la même famille qu'est
ce qu'on voulait nous faire
on va faire une côte de boeuf
d'aquitaine de blondes d'aquitaine à la
sauce à l'ail cette excellente ce n'est
pas une goutte de baisse limité ça mais
si micheline mais elle a été désossée
elle est belle elle est belle elle est
superbe et voix magnifique bien ce
qu'est ce que vous allez c'est bon alors
j'ai mis de la guerre c'est dans la
poêle oui et je vais m'y mettre mais un
mot nine en chemise
oui là dedans c'est à dire qu'il n'est
pas et plus je n'ai pas éplucher et vous
allez faire dorer un peu voilà je vais
rester cinq minutes
oui tout va pendant ce temps je vais en
parler vous une vieille folle et
maintenant je vais préparer marc saufs
qu'est ce qu'il vous faut buvén
d'échalotes et qu'est ce qui vous fait
alors là j'ai mis mes casseroles sur le
feu
bon je vais prendre ce poste but si vite
repris dans le gard 2 litres un quart de
litre de verre voilà très bien et de
l'échalote hachée non plus une bonne
poignée la non madame arraché et je
parie que vous allez laisser réduire sa
tout doucement tout doucement je vais
finir dash et celle là oui parce qu'il y
en aurait passé voilà il tout
doucettement savard et du ca va réduire
ça sans rien y ajouter dormir pendant
que ça réduit qu'est ce que vous allez
on va s'occuper de notre coq je vois des
baies de genièvre et des grains de
poivre
qu'est ce que vous allez voir là et de
jouer les écraser avec qualcomm on n'a
pas le moulin vous avez donné votre
casserole c'est un nouveau système comme
ça un truc ça oui s'empêche de glisser
la regarder
tandis que si vous tapiez dessus il
arrivait à les écraser avec les biens
sur des roues avant
eh ben il doit vous allez faire pareil
poivre pareil sauf avait les moyens de
bord il faut bien parce que même si sur
un petit peu grosse mais pourquoi elles
sont un peu con car c'est comme si voilà
alors est ce la même chose de pouvoir y
des mots clés sont comme nulle autre
pareille s'écrasait bois dur que le
genièvre dont il est très facile
d'intéresser du sec c'est tout voilà
formidable jeu mais large de tous ces
noms voilà c'est ce qu'on appelle du
poivre concassé
vous mélangez tout ça tout ça et après
et je vais me frotter ma viande avec
tout ça là je vais en mettre partout où
voilà des deux côtés hop
qu'est ce qu'elle est belle on sent
qu'elle va être bonne puisque sam way il
faut dire que la blonde d'aquitaine
n'était pas mal en bout et même si ce
n'est pas celle qui était à côté de nous
qu'on a mangé en or et la voilà du
soleil noires des deux côtés oui
regardez comme c'est bien rester le
pouvoir je me remettre même un petit peu
il a écrit recommencions le grill sur le
grill pour l'achat d'un bien donner un
petit coup d'oeil là bas si mais je
pense que là il est pratiquement cuit ça
ça réduit un petit peu car c'est très
bien s'occuper de notre époque où tout
va bien là alors je vous passe le gris
le traître parce que j'imagine que vous
allez utiliser cette belle cheminée
puisque nous avons la chance d'avoir la
voilà que ce joli ça mon dieu que c'est
joli et je vais le faire griller la
braise maïté très chaude
il faut qu'elles soient douces eu
pratiquement morte
bon là elle est impeccable et là les
foules à combien de temps vous croyez
pour que sa vie faut la regarder ça
dépend de la braise mais là je parle
cinq dix minutes déjà et que leur
affaire en attendant eh bien on va
préparer nos filets de boeuf
falah dacquoise qu'est ce qu'il nous
faut pour cette recette de l'armagnac du
tir d'une nouveauté
il est bon vous allez voir de l'oignon
du persil des baies de genièvre de
l'échalote des grains de poivre et
évidemment notre jolie viande khitma
maïté ça ce sont des steaks magnifique
qui ont été coupées dans un filet à un
fil et que ce soit à droite pour
descendre alors je mets mes steak dans
cette petite terrine oui voilà tous les
quatre oui j'y mets de l'oignon que je
vais couper
oui voilà
oui je vous aide un peu trop faire plus
vite ah oui pour l'union pour le coupé
comme ça et en deux en deux voilà vous
allez voir sa vie après ça les arroser
non vous allez maintenant d'autres
choses avant non gilberte retourne
arrosée oui mais ça va être excellent
mais ce que je trouve curieux c'est
justement arroser une belle viande comme
ça on a envie de la faire tout ça mais
au fait qu'on a trouvé un
voilà dans de très vieux cahiers grand
oui vous savez ces recettes d'autrefois
qui était écrite avec la vieille plume
peut-être des sergent-major m'ont appelé
ça et à l'encré violette
oui mais en travaux croyait pas compris
ce qui arrivait avec les viandes mes
voyages à l'autre ils n'avaient pas le
frigidaire autrefois alors là vienne se
conservait pas lui voler les maisons
remarque il faisait pas choquant mais
d'un arrêt mais elle prenait plus ou
moins une boue et quand ça avait
l'avenir de le passer c'est par là les
recettes anciennes toujours énormément
de pistes sauf que voilà et de marina de
et de sang se relever voilà les
conditions à quel est notre blonde
n'aurait éventuellement passer comme ça
c'est presque du gafi ça se met enfin il
faut préserver les traditions aussi quoi
voilà je mets le poivre j'ai mis des
baies de genièvre où je mets des baies
de genièvre ont un peu de persil juste
les feuilles
voilà
oui pas mal de choses cela est les
jeunes entrent à m la voilà et vous
arrêtez avec quoi l'armagnac
je m'en doutais alors là il faut
recouvrir c'est pour ça qu'on veut mais
après parce qu'il faut découvrir tout ça
oui
là ça devient d'ailleurs faux et les
gens vont dire mon dieu l'a d'ores mais
il faut ce qu'il faut après le kirsch un
petit verre de kirsch armand j'appelle
ça un grand verre de kirsch ont même été
regardée fauthoux et oui voilà bon poids
bonne mesure et combien de tomber le cap
rouge à 24 heures mais pendant ce temps
les échalotes maïté au réduit à 5
complètement impeccable laqué cuit il
est parfait on a tous terminés non je
vais finir ma sauce et vous aller me
chercher l'entrecôte qui est dans la
cheminée g20 gay voilà elle est bien
jolie l'aïoli howie superbe impeccable
je vais toujours vous apporter le plus
beau gage rideau c'est bien joli aussi
regarder - visa a oui on va la sortir va
remettre dans le plat au superbe ou et
serbes ont fait pas mieux l'un bon eh
bien il ne reste plus qu'à présenter ce
plan il manque votre source quand même
oui mais les jolies je vais le passer
voilà je vais bien écraser tous ces
petits oignons qui avait autant des
échalotes tu croises échalotes
oui tout ça très réduit très réduit
voilà et vous à les arroser la viande
vous le savez à part non non non non non
non non je vais avant cela vient de tout
simplement comme ceux ci est devant on a
un petit peu de purée d'ail par jour
parce que tout le monde ne l'aiment pas
oui et puis ça donne beaucoup de vos
loyers en milieu fermé
regardez moi ça c'est ce joli vous savez
on a envie d'y revenir mais on n'a pas
fini nous reste à faire l'autre recette
les filets de boeuf à la dacquoise alors
à tricher un peu parce qu'on les avait
mis à mariner cela seillière alors ils
ont bien changé de couleur voilà alors
on les prend on en avait tous tirent
dessus je vais laisser chez les époux et
les éponger ou deux ça va aller là oui
voilà c'est un vrai c'est tellement
tendre que ça ça se coupe en trouve à la
violence et la qualité
c'est tellement bon sens veut y aller
mais alors voilà je les mets dans ma
poire à travers à cela et là je ne
savais pas je ne pense pas puisque tout
sept aps la marinade et est assaisonné
pour réparer un légume pour les
accompagner quelques échalotes qui
fondent qui fondent et je vais m besset
paris et chabot
voilà très bien et je m'en vais
maintenant retourner
il ya eu tout de musique qui n'est pas
désagréable ans que j'entends d'arthur
est retourné ma viande
voilà regarder ça alors là c'est au bout
de chaque arrêt mais quand on veut et
pendant ces zones aux mains dans les
temps de cuisson en 2002 portant de
cuisson et entendu on à killem presque
bleu l'enseignement et hérite à voir on
va la mettre saignante
voilà je vais mettre un petit peu de jus
de marinade dans les légumes
oui tout petit peu pour donner le bon
goût de l'armagnac et du coup c'est bon
et je vais sortir ma viande
alors ça c'est signant se saignant 6 mai
le procureur du monde mc niaré quand
même voilà
et bien voilà et voilà était la leur et
les recettes qu'il faut quand même le
rappeler qui est une recette très
ancienne
conçu à l'époque où il n'y avait pas de
frigidaires il nous était difficile de
garder les belles viande mais on peut
s'amuser à retrouver ses goûts anciens
c'est l'hiver c'est amusant de changer
de temps en temps on en vient on ne
l'est pas plus franchement pas ce que
vous voulez mettre assez niant pas trop
saignant que vous voulez manger même
assez vite mais elle aime le bon boeuf
et la belle blonde d'aquitaine
à bientôt au revoir merci d'être resté
avec nous ce moment bon appétit et merci
[Musique]